This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. In November 1971, a man showed up at a flight counter for Northwest Orient Airlines in Portland. He asked to buy a one-way ticket to Seattle. The man provided his name when he bought the ticket. Dan Cooper. He was carrying a black briefcase. Once on board the aircraft and en route to Seattle, the man showed a flight attendant the contents of his briefcase. It looked like a bomb.
这里是《隐秘大脑》。我是香卡·维丹特。1971年11月，在波特兰的西北东方航空公司登机柜台前出现了一名男子。他要求买一张去西雅图的单程票。这名男子买票时留下了自己的名字。丹·库珀。他提着一个黑色的公文包。一上飞机并在飞往西雅图的途中，这名男子就向一名空乘人员展示了他的公文包里的东西。它看起来像一枚炸弹。
In return for releasing passengers unharmed, he demanded $200,000 when the plane landed. He also added an odd request. He wanted four parachutes. After the plane landed in Seattle, the ransom and parachutes were delivered. Dan Cooper allowed the passengers to disembark, but kept the crew on board. He demanded the plane be refueled and fly to Mexico City. board. He demanded the plane be refueled and fly to Mexico City. The plane took off a second time. The hijacker ordered the crew to stay in the cockpit. He also demanded the curtains between the coach cabin and first class be closed. With no one watching him, he opened the rear exit on the plane and leaped with his parachute and his money into a moonless night. Dan Cooper was never caught.
作为释放乘客且不伤害他们的交换，他要求在飞机降落时支付20万美元。他还提出了一个奇怪的要求。他想要四个降落伞。飞机在西雅图降落后，赎金和降落伞被送了上去。丹·库珀允许乘客下机，但把机组人员留在了机上。他要求给飞机重新加油并飞往墨西哥城。机上人员留在了机上。他要求给飞机重新加油并飞往墨西哥城。飞机第二次起飞了。劫机者命令机组人员待在驾驶舱里。他还要求拉上经济舱和头等舱之间的帘子。在无人监视的情况下，他打开了飞机的后舱门，带着降落伞和钱跳入了一个没有月光的夜晚。丹·库珀从未被抓住。
His identity remains a mystery. Clearly, the man who showed up at the airline counter that day was not who he said he was. The story of his hijacking, while real, is the stuff of movies and novels. Today on the show, we look at how many of us go to great lengths to disguise who we are. Most of the time, it isn't because we are planning anything nefarious, it's because we want to fit in or be taken seriously. But such disguises don't just fool others.
他的身份依然是个谜。显然，那天出现在航空公司柜台前的那个男子并不是他说的那个人。他的劫机故事虽然真实，却像是电影和小说里的情节。今天的节目中，我们来看看我们当中有多少人为了伪装自己的真实身份而煞费苦心。大多数时候，这不是因为我们在策划什么邪恶的事情，而是因为我们想要融入集体或被认真对待。但这种伪装不仅会愚弄别人。
They have powerful effects on us. What happens when we pretend we are not who we are? This week on Hidden Brain. Who are we really, and how much of our real selves can we show to the world? These are questions all of us wrestle with. Sometimes we decide to bear it all. Other times, we decide to cover up. Kenji Yoshino is a legal scholar at New
它们对我们有着强烈的吸引力。当我们假装自己不是自己时，会发生什么？本周在《隐秘大脑》中。我们究竟是谁，我们可以向世界展示多少真实的自我？这些都是我们所有人都在纠缠的问题。有时我们决定全盘托出。有时，我们决定掩盖。吉野贤治是纽约的一位法学学者
York University who studies the effects these choices have on us and on those around us. Kenji Yoshino, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much for having me. Kenji, take me back in time to the story of a very prominent American who went to great lengths to manage how people saw him. You've studied America's 32nd president, Franklin Delano Roosevelt. Tell me his story. So Franklin Delano Roosevelt was struck by polio,
大学研究这些选择对我们以及我们周围的人产生的影响。吉野贤治，欢迎来到《隐秘大脑》。非常感谢邀请我。贤治，带我回到过去，去了解一位非常杰出的美国人的故事，他煞费苦心来管理人们如何看待他。你研究过美国的第32任总统富兰克林·德拉诺·罗斯福。给我讲讲他的故事。富兰克林·德拉诺·罗斯福当时患上了小儿麻痹症，
and in the wake of that had a motor disability where he was in a wheelchair. And he made every effort to downplay this to the American public. And that included having photographs taken of him only from the waist up. And he was able to minimize or edit his public persona so that his disability was in the background rather than the foreground of his interactions with others. And I am certain that on this day my fellow Americans expect that on my induction into
在此之后导致了运动残疾，需要坐轮椅。他竭尽全力向美国公众淡化这一点。这包括只拍摄他腰部以上的照片。他能够尽量减少或编辑自己的公众形象，使他的残疾在他的背景中，而不是在他与他人互动的最前沿。我确信，在今天，我的同胞们期望在我宣誓就任时
the presidency, I will address them with a candor and a decision. When I think back to photographs I've seen of FDR, I often see him, you know, sitting behind a desk with people standing around him. And of course, he looks very presidential when he does that. But perhaps some of this was also with a view to hiding the fact that he found it difficult to stand and to walk. That's exactly right. And in fact, we know that he used to make sure that he was seated behind a table before
我将以坦诚和果断的态度向他们发表讲话。当我回想起我见过的FDR的照片时，我经常看到他，你知道，坐在书桌后面，周围站着人。当然，他这样做的时候看起来非常具有总统风范。但也可能其中一部分原因是为了掩饰他发现自己很难站立和行走这一事实。完全正确。事实上，我们知道他过去常常确保自己在内阁进入之前就坐在桌子后面
his cabinet entered so that nobody needed to see him kind of laboriously getting in or out of his seat. So it was a very kind of manicured and orchestrated and choreographed appearance that he gave to the world. I understand that FDR also had a car specially designed for him? Yes, so this is a car that he could drive with his hands only, so things like the gas pedal or the brakes could all be manipulated through his hands, and he made a special point of being photographed driving around in this car to give the impression that he was just as capable of driving as anybody else. What's striking about the story of course is that people knew that the president had a disability that he had polio. It wasn't a secret but yet he went to these lengths in some ways to give the impression
这样就没人需要看到他有些吃力地坐下或站起来了。因此，他呈现给世界的是一种非常精心修饰、精心策划和编排的外表。我听说FDR还让人专门为他设计了一辆车？是的，这是一辆他只能用双手驾驶的车，所以像油门或刹车之类的东西都可以通过他的双手来操作，他特别强调让人拍下他驾驶这辆车的照片，给人一种他和其他人一样有能力驾驶的印象。当然，这个故事引人注目的是，人们知道总统有残疾，他得过小儿麻痹症。这并不是秘密，但他还是在某些方面费尽心思给人一种他一切都好的印象。
that he was okay. That's exactly right. So again, he wasn't trying to fool anybody nor could he have, but what he was trying to do was to soften the impression that this made a difference. I want to play you some tape, Kenji, featuring Margaret Thatcher, the former Prime Minister of Britain. In 1980, the year she gave the speech, unemployment was rising in Britain and the economy was in recession. Some of her critics urged her to execute a U-turn reversing the changes she had made. Here's how she responded. To those waiting with bated breaths for that favorite media catchphrase, the U-turn, I have only one thing to say. U-turn if you want to. The ladies not for turning.
完全正确。所以再说一次，他并不是在试图愚弄任何人，他也不可能做到这一点，但他真正试图做的是淡化这带来的影响。我想播放一段录音，贤治，里面是英国前首相玛格丽特·撒切尔。1980年，也就是她发表这篇演讲的那一年，英国的失业率正在上升，经济陷入衰退。她的一些批评者敦促她来个“180度大转弯”，扭转她所做出的改变。她是这样回应的。对于那些屏住呼吸等待媒体最喜欢的口头禅——“180度大转弯”的人，我只有一句话要说：你们想转就转吧。这位女士绝不退缩。
Listening to that clip, Kenji, it's hard not to notice Margaret Thatcher's distinctive speaking voice. Margaret Thatcher's distinctive speaking voice. Yes, absolutely. And one of the things that, like, you know, FDR, she did was to carefully, you know, orchestrate her speaking voice. So when she was first standing for Prime Minister, her handlers came to her and said, you need to go into voice coaching. Wow. And what they were doing was saying to her, look, you speak with a working class accent,
听着那段剪辑，贤治，很难不注意到玛格丽特·撒切尔那标志性的说话声音。玛格丽特·撒切尔那标志性的说话声音。是的，绝对是。像FDR一样，她做的一件事就是仔细地，你知道的，编排她的说话声音。所以当她第一次竞选首相时，她的幕僚找到她说，你需要去接受语音培训。哇。他们对她说的是，听着，你带有工人阶级的口音，
so you need to posh up your voice, your grocer's daughter. And so they told her that the voice coaching would allow her to lower her voice so that she would have more executive presence. She dutifully went into the voice coaching and emerged on the other side with a more patrician, resonant voice.
所以你需要让你的声音听起来更高雅一点，你毕竟是个杂货商的女儿。于是他们告诉她，语音培训可以让她降低嗓音，从而更有领导气场。她顺从地接受了语音培训，最后以一种更具贵族气质、更有共鸣的声音出现。
And her voice became one of the most distinctive aspects of her, where when you hear that voice, you hear the voice of authority. No confidence on money, no confidence on the economy. So yes, the right honorable gentleman would be glad to hand it all over. But what is the point? Then try to get elected to Parliament only to hand over your sterling and to hand over the powers of this country. And of course, I mean, she was known as the Iron Lady, and in some ways that voice added to that impression. Exactly right. So in this case, Margaret Thatcher wasn't hiding a physical disability. She was hiding the fact that she came from a blue collar background.
她的声音成了她最标志性的特征之一，当你听到那个声音时，你听到的是权威的声音。在金钱上没有信心，在经济上没有信心。所以是的，尊敬的议员先生会很高兴把它全部交出去。但有什么意义呢？然后费尽心思当选议员，却要把你的英镑和这个国家的权力拱手相让。当然，我的意思是，她被称为“铁娘子”，在某种程度上，那种声音加深了这种印象。完全正确。所以在这个案子里，玛格丽特·撒切尔不是在隐瞒身体残疾。她是在隐瞒自己出身于蓝领阶层的事实。
But again, it wasn't a secret that she came from a blue collar background. People knew that she was a grocer's daughter, but in some way she again was giving people the illusion that she came from a blue collar background, people knew that she was a gross-sourced daughter, but in some ways she again was giving people the illusion that she wasn't. Exactly. So here we have a second example of someone who is not trying to hide who they are, but is trying to sort of manage or soften or engage in impression management because she knows that she has a quality that is an outsider quality that people are not going to accept as easily in someone who occupies a position of power. I want to play you another piece of tape, Kenji. This one features an actor, Ben Kingsley, talking about what it was like to be offered the lead role in the movie Gandhi, a performance for which he would ultimately receive an Academy
但再次强调，她出身于蓝领阶层并不是什么秘密。人们知道她是个杂货商的女儿，但在某种程度上，她再次给人们一种错觉，即她出身于蓝领阶层，人们知道她是个杂货商的女儿，但在某种程度上，她再次给人们一种错觉，即她不是。没错。所以这里我们有第二个例子，这个人不是在试图隐藏自己是谁，而是在试图管理、软化或进行印象管理，因为她知道自己有一种局外人的特质，而这种特质在一个占据权力地位的人身上是不会那么容易被人们接受的。我想播放另一段录音，贤治。这一段是一个演员本·金斯利，谈论获得电影《甘地》主角机会时的感受，凭借这部电影的表演，他最终获得了奥斯卡奖。
Award. He's recounting here how it felt like to look in the mirror after he was made to look like Mahatma Gandhi. He didn't know at this point whether director Richard Attenborough, who had spent years trying to make the movie, was going to give him the part. And during this moment where I'm staring in the mirror, Attenborough walked into the dressing room. Dickie slumped into a chair. I thought, oh dear, this doesn't look good. He slumped. He collapsed.
他在这里回忆了当他被化妆成圣雄甘地后照镜子时的感受。当时他并不知道导演理查德·阿滕伯勒（Richard Attenborough）是否会把这个角色给他，阿滕伯勒为了拍这部电影已经花了数年时间。就在我盯着镜子看的这段时间里，阿滕伯勒走进了化妆间。迪基瘫坐在椅子上。我想，哦天哪，这看起来不妙。他瘫坐着。他垮了下来。
I didn't realize that it was the collapse of a man who'd reached the end of a very, very, very long journey. Because from his collapsed posture, he murmured, Ben, I want you to do it. long journey because from his collapsed posture he murmured, Ben, I want you to do it. So Kenji, actors of course are professionally trained to disguise themselves. Ben Kingsley was pretending to be someone he was not, but you say he wasn't just playing the role of Gandhi?
我当时没有意识到这是一个经历了非常、非常、非常漫长旅程的人的崩溃。因为从他垮塌的姿势中，他喃喃地说：本，我要你演。漫长的旅程，因为从他垮塌的姿势中，他喃喃地说：本，我要你演。所以贤治，演员当然受过专业训练来伪装自己。本 Kingsley 当时在假装成另一个人，但你说他不仅仅是在扮演甘地这个角色？
Yes, so Ben Kingsley was born Krishna Banji and he changed his name when he began his theatrical career because he thought that his birth name would limit the roles that he would be able to acquire. So the irony is that he became Ben Kingsley, but then also went back to playing Gandhi. So there's a kind of Russian doll nesting quality to this. But the thing that he has in common with the other two figures you were describing is again, he understood that it could be career consequential for him
是的，本·金斯利原名克里希纳·班吉（Krishna Banji），他在开始戏剧生涯时改了名字，因为他认为自己的本名会限制他能接到的角色。所以具有讽刺意味的是，他变成了本·金斯利，但后来又去演了甘地。所以这有一种俄罗斯套娃式的嵌套性质。但他和你们刚才描述的其他两个人物的共同点再次在于，他明白将自己完整真实的一面呈现出来可能会对他的职业生涯产生影响。
to present himself as his full authentic self. And he modulated aspects of his identity because he knew exactly what the culture needed from him and he assimilated to that culture. And of course, he's not the only actor to have done so. There is a long list of actors and musicians and performers who have changed their names to have, you know, stage names that sound more charismatic, if you will, than their given names. Absolutely. And they tend to be sort of more popular names that are in the semantic stock, right?
他调节了自己身份的各个方面，因为他确切地知道文化对他的要求是什么，并且他融入了这种文化。当然，他并不是唯一这样做的演员。有长长的一单演员、音乐家和表演者都改过名字，拥有，你知道的，听起来比他们的本名更有魅力的艺名。绝对是的。而且它们往往是语义库中某种更受欢迎的名字，对吧？
And so you tend to see actors changing their names in the direction of something that will be more kind of broadly intelligible, more memorable, more part of the semantic stock, right, of the country that they're performing in. All these figures were very visible. Franklin Roosevelt, Margaret Thatcher, and Ben Kingsley lived in the public eye. And yet, there were aspects of themselves that they played down. They were hiding, but hiding in plain sight. When we come back, the subtle ways in which we all disguise our identities, and what this subterfuge costs us. You're listening to Hidden Brain.
因此，你会发现演员们改名的方向是更广泛易懂、更令人难忘、更融入他们演出的国家的语义库中的东西，对吧？所有这些人物都非常引人注目。富兰克林·罗斯福、玛格丽特·撒切尔和本·金斯利都生活在公众的视线中。然而，他们身上都有一些被他们淡化的方面。他们在隐藏，却隐藏在显眼的地方。稍后回来，我们将探讨我们所有人掩饰身份的微妙方式，以及这种花招让我们付出的代价。您正在收听的是《隐秘大脑》。
I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. Kenji Yoshino is a legal scholar at New York University. He says that people who feel shame about their identities or fear how they will be treated by others often disguise themselves in three ways, all of which he has done himself. Kenji, let's spend a little time with your own story. You first realized you needed to disguise who you were when you were at boarding school. What did you feel you needed to hide?
我是香卡·维丹塔。这里是《隐秘大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔。吉野贤治是纽约大学的一名法学学者。他说，对自己的身份感到羞耻或害怕他人如何对待自己的人，经常通过三种方式伪装自己，所有这些他自己都经历过。贤治，让我们花点时间来聊聊你自己的故事。你第一次意识到你需要伪装自己是在寄宿学校的时候。你觉得你需要隐藏什么？
I came to the realization that I was gay fairly early in my life, and I think I knew that from a very young age, but was still in this phase of hoping that this would go away. And one of the ways in which I willed it to go away was by having a girlfriend. And of course, this has collateral consequences on other people. So I look back with regret on what I put her through because I wasn't able to be my fully authentic self. But this was in the mid-'80s, and I think that this is, unfortunately, a very common narrative. I understand that when you got to college, you directed all your energies into academic pursuits. Were you using your studies to hide your identity now? Yes. I think that this is something that I have heard in a lot of LGBT
我很早就意识到自己是同性恋，我想我在很小的时候就知道这一点，但仍然处于希望这种感觉会消失的阶段。我希望它消失的方法之一就是交一个女朋友。当然，这会对其他人产生连锁反应。所以我回想起我让她经历的一切时感到后悔，因为我无法成为完全真实的自己。但这是在80年代中期，我认为这不幸是一个非常普遍的故事。我听说当你进入大学时，你把所有的精力都投入到了学术追求上。你当时是在用学业来隐藏你的身份吗？是的。我想这是我从许多LGBT身上听到过的事情
individuals, and perhaps more generally individuals who are kind of overachievers in one domain of their life in order to compensate for some perceived lack in another domain. Poetry was a great solace for me because it allowed me to articulate what I was going through without necessarily being so public about it.
个体，或许更广义地说，是在生活的一个领域中过度成就的人，以弥补另一个领域中感到的某种缺失。诗歌对我是极大的慰藉，因为它让我能够表达我正在经历的事情，而不必表现得那么公开。
So poetry was more public than thought, but it was more private than prose. And I found a great comfort in being able to express myself without feeling I was completely exposed. was completely exposed. So after college, you went to England on a Rhodes Scholarship, but you became depressed when you were in England. Tell me what happened, Kenji. It was a very, very dark time in my life.
所以诗歌比思想更公开，但比散文更私密。我发现在不感到完全暴露的情况下表达自己是一种极大的安慰。感到完全暴露。所以在大学毕业后，你凭借罗德奖学金去了英国，但你在英国时变得抑郁了。告诉我发生了什么，贤治。那是我生命中非常非常黑暗的一段时期。
The only consistent foray I made from my college rooms and the first month I was there was to go to the college chapel where I prayed to God's I wasn't even sure I believed in for conversion to heterosexuality. So this is the most aggressive form of assimilation where you desire to change the underlying identity altogether. And it's very difficult Shankar for me to remember that young man knelt down
我刚到那里的第一个月，除了去大学的小教堂向那些我甚至不确定自己是否相信的神祈祷让我变成异性恋之外，我没有离开过宿舍半步。这是最激进的同化形式，你渴望彻底改变潜在的身份。香卡，我很难回想起那个跪下祈祷的年轻人
in prayer because he so ardently wished the annihilation of the human being I have become. So I'm now currently happily married, my husband and I have two kids, and so on and so forth. But that would have been unimaginable to that young man. This is 1991. He just thought, if I'm going to have any kind of life at all, not just a professional life, but also, perhaps more importantly to him at the time, a personal life of marriage and children, that it was inconceivable that you could be an openly gay person and have that life. So what I desperately wanted was to convert and to change the underlying identity. At some point during your time in England, Kenji, you went to see a psychiatrist.
因为他如此迫切地希望我所变成的这个人彻底消失。我现在已经幸福地结婚了，我和我丈夫有两个孩子，诸如此类。但这对于那个年轻人来说是不可想象的。那是1991年。他只是想，如果我要过上任何生活，不仅是职业生活，而且对他当时来说可能更重要的，是婚姻和孩子的个人生活，公开作为一个同性恋并拥有那种生活是不可想象的。所以我拼命想要的是皈依并改变底层身份。贤治，在你在英国期间的某个时候，你去看了一位心理医生。
Tell me what happened when you talked with him and how it turned out. There was one pivotal conversation that became a touchstone for my young adult life where he at one point said, can you just describe to me what it feels like to be attracted to somebody? Like who are you attracted to? Describe someone who is attractive. And I said, I absolutely cannot do that because it is perverted. And he said, in words that I will never forget, it is not perverted, it is thwarted. And that sort of paradigm shift from thinking about my own desires as being something that were properly stigmatized to thinking that this is actually just something that is blocked, right, was just a transformative shift in my own thinking.
告诉我当你与他交谈时发生了什么，结果如何。有一次关键的对话成为了我青年时代的一个试金石，他当时说，你能向我描述一下被某人吸引是什么感觉吗？比如你被谁吸引？描述一个有吸引力的人。我说，我绝对做不到，因为那是变态的。他说了一句我永远不会忘记的话：这不是变态，而是受阻。这种范式转变，从认为我自己的欲望是某种本应受到污名化的东西，到认为这实际上只是某种被阻碍了的东西，对吧，对我的思想来说真是一个颠覆性的转变。
So this insight helped you accept your identity as a gay man, but when you returned to the United States to go to law school, were you open about being gay? I was not, and I think about this as a movement from one phase of assimilation to another. So if the first phase was trying to convert and responding to really the demand for conversion, which I experienced in society at large, the second phase was, I'm not going to convert, but I am going to pass. And what I mean by that is I had by that point accepted the fact that I was gay and I was not trying to change the underlying identity.
所以这个洞察帮助你接受了你作为同性恋男性的身份，但当你回到美国读法学院时，你对自己的同性恋身份坦诚吗？我没有，我觉得这是一个从同化阶段向另一个同化阶段的转变。因此，如果第一阶段是试图皈依并响应社会的皈依要求（我在整个社会中都经历过这种要求），那么第二阶段就是，我不会皈依，但我会伪装（passing）。我的意思是，我当时已经接受了自己是同性恋的事实，并没有试图改变潜在的身份。
But I was nonetheless extremely closeted and not willing to share that identity with anyone in the community around me. Kenji saw the school was offering a class about sexual orientation and the law. He desperately wanted to take the course, but wondered what message it would send. And I really debated whether or not I should take the class because I thought if I sign up for this class, it's a very small community. The class lists are all posted in the hallway. And the moment where I put my name on that list, I have effectively outed myself to the entire community, I thought.
但我仍然极度隐瞒，不愿与周围社区的任何人分享这一身份。贤治看到学校提供了一门关于性取向与法律的课程。他非常想选这门课，但又想这会发出什么信号。我真的很纠结我是否应该选这门课，因为我想如果我报名这门课，这是一个非常小的社区。课程名单都贴在走廊里。我想，就在我把名字写到那个名单上的那一刻，我实际上已经向整个社区出柜了。
At that time, the only people who would be caught, taking a class called sexual orientation in the law were members of the LGBTQIA plus community and then maybe some women, some righteous straight women, but a straight man would not be caught, you know, touching a class like this with a 10-foot pole. Kenji eventually started to come out of the closet. He got a boyfriend, Paul, but went to great lengths to hide Paul from the world. This is a point of real tension in my relationship with him because Paul, quite rightly, felt
在那个时候，会被抓到选修一门名为“性取向与法律”的课程的人，只有LGBTQIA+社区的成员，也许还有一些女性，一些正直的直女，而直男是绝对不会用十英尺长的杆子去碰这样一门课的。贤治最终开始出柜了。他交了一个男朋友保罗，但竭尽全力对世界隐藏保罗。这是我和他关系中一个真正的紧张点，因为保罗很合理地觉得
that I was downplaying him or hiding him in ways that suggested I was ashamed of the relationship and that he you know, he really deserved better. And the idea of holding somebody's hand in public or showing public displays of same-sex affection were all sort of verboten at this time for me. So eventually, Kenji, you became a law professor, and at one point, you received a piece of advice from a colleague that backed up your decision to disguise yourself in the way that you were disguising yourself.
我贬低了他或隐藏了他，这表明我对这段关系感到羞耻，而他，你知道的，确实值得更好的对待。在公共场合牵手或公开表现同性爱意这种事，对我来说当时都是禁忌。所以最终，贤治，你成为了一名法学教授，在某个时候，你得到了同事的一个建议，这个建议支持了你以那种方式伪装自己的决定。
What was this advice? So the advice that I got when I started teaching as a junior professor was by a very well-meaning, very kind colleague who wanted only good things for me. And he put his arm around me as we were walking down the hall. And he said, Kenji, you'll have a lot smoother ride to getting tenure if you are a homosexual professional rather than a professional homosexual.
这是什么建议？所以当我作为一名初级教授开始教书时，我得到的建议来自一位非常善良、非常好的同事，他对我只有美好的祝愿。我们在走廊上走着时，他搂住我的肩膀说：贤治，如果你作为一个“同性恋专业人士”而不是一个“专业的同性恋”，你在争取终身教授职位的道路上会顺利得多。
And I knew exactly what he meant. What he meant was, you'll do much better if you are the mainstream constitutional law professor who teaches separation of powers and federalism and judicial review and just happens to be gay on the side as a extracurricular activity than you will if you are the gay rights professor who teaches gay rights subjects and writes on gay rights issues and works on gay rights cases. Unfortunately, of course, it was the latter that I wanted to do. This was now 1996, the time when the ice was finally breaking up on the LGBTQIA plus landscape.
我完全明白他的意思。他的意思是，如果你是一个教授权力分立、联邦制和司法审查的主流宪法法学教授，而同性恋只是你作为课外活动顺便带有的属性，你会混得好得多；而如果你是一个教授同性恋权利科目、撰写同性恋权利议题、参与同性恋权利案件的“同性恋权利教授”，你就不会那么好过。不幸的是，我当然想做后者。这已经是1996年了，当时LGBTQIA+领域的坚冰终于开始融解。
The Romer versus Evans case had just been decided. It was really clear that we were barreling our way towards Lawrence versus Texas in 2003, which was the Brown v. Boer, the gay rights movement. And I did not want to be on the sidelines for that. But what he was clearly saying was, if you want to get tenure here, you really need to manage your identity and there's just a limit
罗默诉埃文斯案刚刚裁决。很明显，我们正全速驶向2003年的劳伦斯诉德克萨斯案，那是同性恋权利运动的布朗诉教育委员会案。我不想在这件事上作旁观者。但他显然在说，如果你想在这里获得终身教职，你真的需要管理好你的身份，而且在这个环境中，你只能“同性恋”到一定程度，
to how gay you can be in this environment and expect to succeed. So in other words, be gay but don't flaunt it. Exactly. And the reason that that was so utterly painful for me was it was someone I really admired and trusted. And he was saying, actually there's another hurdle that you need to wrestle with, right? Which is you don't need to be straight, right? So you don't need to convert. You don't need to be in the closet, i.e. you don't need to pass.
才能期望成功。换句话说，做同性恋但不要炫耀。完全正确。这件事让我感到如此痛苦的原因是，他是我非常钦佩和信任的人。而他说，实际上你还需要应对另一个障碍，对吧？也就是你不需要是直的，对吧？所以你不需要皈依。你不需要留在衣橱里，也就是说你不需要伪装（passing）。
But you do need to, as you put it, Shankar, not flaunt. You need to downplay, mute, edit your identity so that the rest of us can feel more comfortable around you. So that was a moment when I had this pit in my stomach and I realized that I needed to engage in yet more kind of identity management when I thought that the era of that was long over in my own life. So one day you came by a book that life. So one day you came by a book that transformed your understanding of what was happening to
但正如你所说，香卡，你确实需要“不炫耀”。你需要淡化、柔化、编辑你的身份，以便我们其他人能在你身边感到更舒适。所以那一刻，我的胃里一阵绞痛，我意识到我需要参与更多种类的身份管理，而我原本以为我生活中的那个时代早已结束了。所以有一天，你偶然读到了一本书，生活。所以有一天，你偶然读到了一本书，它改变了你对发生在你身上和周围事情的理解。贤治，你能给我描绘一下这个顿悟的画面吗？
you and what was happening around you. Can you paint me a picture of this epiphany, Kenji? Yes, I'm sure this will resonate with most readers, right, who read a book and it so aptly describes something in their own life that they realize that they will never be able to see the world in the same way again. And that book for me was Irving Goffman's book, Stigma, Notes on the Management of Spoiled Identity. So Irving Goffman is a very eminent sociologist, and one of the things that he was smartest about was the presentation of the self.
是的，我相信这会引起大多数读者的共鸣，对吧，他们读了一本书，它如此贴切地描述了他们自己生活中的某些事，以至于他们意识到他们将再也无法以同样的方式看待世界了。对我和那本书而言，就是欧文·戈夫曼的《 stigma: 污名：受损身份管理札记》。所以欧文·戈夫曼是一位非常杰出的社会学家，他最擅长的领域之一就是自我的呈现。
So in this book about stigma, he said that individuals who are quite open about the fact that they belong to a stigmatized group, open because they either cannot or will not, you know, hide that fact, nonetheless expend an enormous amount of energy to downplay that identity so that others around them can have greater comfort. And he called this phenomenon covering. And the reason that this is so transformative for me was that I understood to my very bones, right, what I was being asked to do, but I didn't have a word for it. I had a word for, yes, change your identity. That was conversion.
所以在关于污名的这本书中，他说那些对于自己属于一个受污 stigma 群体这一事实非常公开的人——公开是因为他们不能也不愿隐藏这个事实——尽管如此，仍然花费了巨量的精力来淡化这个身份，以便他们周围的人能感到更舒适。他把这种现象称为“掩饰”（covering）。这件事对我如此具有颠覆性的原因在于，我内心深处完全理解我被要求做什么，但我没有一个词来形容它。我有词来形容：是的，改变你的身份。那是皈依。
I had a word for you can have the identity, but hide it from everybody. That was passing. But I did not have the word for you can be gay and say that you're gay, but make sure that you soften it, mute it, edit it, downplay it, so that other people around you can feel more comfortable. So this I am out of the closet, but I'm still being asked to assimilate in these ways was what I was really struggling with. And I couldn't name it. And what Irving Goffman did,
我有词来形容：你可以拥有这个身份，但把它对所有人隐藏起来。那是伪装（passing）。但我没有词来形容：你可以是同性恋并且说你是同性恋，但一定要把它软化、柔化、编辑、淡化，好让周围的人觉得更舒服。所以这种“我已经出柜了，但仍然被要求以这些方式被同化”正是我当时苦苦挣扎的事情。而且我无法给它命名。欧文·戈夫曼所做的，
and it's really like a throwaway line. I think it's two pages in his book where he talks about this. But he just gave me a word that changed my life because I thought this is what I was being asked to do when that wonderful colleague of mine said to me, be a homosexual professional rather than a professional homosexual, because that colleague
这真的就像一句随口带过的话。我想他在书中花了大约两页纸来谈论这个。但他只是给了我一个改变我生活词汇，因为我想，当那位杰出的同事对我说“做一个同性恋专业人士，而不是一个专业的同性恋”时，我被要求做的就是这个，因为那位同事
was not saying don't be gay or don't say that you're gay. He was saying it's fine for you to be gay and say that you're gay, but don't flaunt it. And covering was what he was asking me to do. So I knew that would forevermore be attuned to these covering demands as the kind of assimilation I would be asked to engage in on the other side of the closet door. And of course, once you had the vocabulary for this, you started to see examples of this
并不是在说不要做同性恋或不要说你是同性恋。他是在说做同性恋并说你是同性恋是可以的，但不要炫耀它。而“掩饰”就是他要求我做的。所以我知道，从那以后，我将永远对这些“掩饰”要求保持敏锐，将其视为我被要求在衣橱门外参与的同化形式。当然，一旦你有了这套词汇，你便开始在更大的文化中看到这方面的例子。
in the larger culture. Everyone knew that FDR had polio, but he goes to great lengths to disguise the fact that he has polio. Everyone knows that Margaret Thatcher is a woman and came from a blue collar background, but she goes to great lengths not to sound overly feminine or overly blue collar. That's exactly right. So once I had this term covering, I was able to see it everywhere. In fact, I was unable not to see it everywhere in social life. And the important insight there is that when we're talking about conversion or when we're
每个人都知道罗斯福有小儿麻痹症，但他煞费苦心地伪装自己有小儿麻痹症的事实。每个人都知道玛格丽特·撒切尔是一个女性，出身于蓝领家庭，但她煞费苦心不让自己听起来过于女性化或过于具有蓝领气息。完全正确。所以一旦我有了“掩饰”这个词，我就能到处看到它。事实上，在社会生活中，我不可能看不到它。其中一个重要的见解是，当我们谈论皈依或谈论伪装时，
talking about passing, these are not strategies that are available to everybody. So if you have a immutable identity like race, you're going to be limited in how much you can convert that or pass. But notice what happens when we get to covering. Covering demands direct themselves at the behavioral aspects of an identity. So that means every single person can cover. So unlike conversion and passing, covering is a truly universal experience
这些并不是对每个人都适用的策略。因此，如果你拥有一个不可变的身份，比如种族，你在多大程度上能皈依或伪装是有限的。但请注意当我们谈到掩饰时会发生什么。掩饰的需求直接针对身份的行为层面。这意味着每一个人都可以进行掩饰。因此，与皈依和伪装不同，掩饰对于任何具有受污名化或局外人身份的人来说，确实是一种普遍体验。
for anyone who has a stigmatized or outsider identity. And I would add to that that I think we understand it is not normal to be completely normal along all dimensions. All of us have some outsider identities, and so therefore all of us will have experienced the covering demand. So again, Margaret Thatcher, Franklin Delano Roosevelt, Ben Kingsley, there's nothing that they could do to convert or to pass with regard to their identities, whether that was disability or gender or race or national origin, but they were all able to cover by modifying aspects of their identity. So I will cover by making sure I'm only photographed from the waist up to hide my disability,
我想补充一点，我认为我们都明白，在所有维度上都做到完全正常是不正常的。我们所有人都有一些局外人身份，因此我们所有人都会经历过掩饰的需求。再说一次，玛格丽特·撒切尔、富兰克林·德拉诺·罗斯福、本·金斯利，他们在残疾、性别、种族或国籍等身份方面，无能为力去皈依或伪装，但他们都能通过修改身份的某些方面来进行掩饰。所以我会通过确保只拍腰部以上的照片来掩饰我的残疾，
or I will cover by going to voice coaching to scrub my working class accent, or I will cover by changing my name, right, so that people don't have immediate associations about what roles I might be appropriate for and pigeonhole me in a very narrow area of the theater world. These are all acts of covering, and they testify to how universal this is. Think about a hard-driving workplace. You're a new mom. Do you hesitate to put up pictures of your children on your desk? That's what Kenji would call covering.
或者我可以通过去上语音培训来洗掉我的工人阶级口音来进行掩饰，或者我可以通过改名字来进行掩饰，对吧，这样人们就不会对适合我的角色产生直接联想，并把我死板地套进戏剧界一个非常狭窄的领域里。这些都是掩饰的行为，它们证明了这是多么普遍。想想一个快节奏、高压的工作场所。你是一位新妈妈。你是否在把孩子的照片放在办公桌上时感到犹豫？这就是贤治所说的“掩饰”。
He cites studies that show that in such workplaces, women face a motherhood penalty. There are social science studies that are quite depressing on this point. Oh, she's now a caregiver. She'll be less committed to work. There's a follow-on study by Beatrice Aranda and Peter Glick that says, is there anything that women can do to mitigate or eliminate the motherhood penalty? As it turns out, there's nothing you can do to eliminate it,
他引用的研究表明，在这类工作场所中，女性面临着生育惩罚。有一些社会科学研究在这个问题上相当令人沮丧。哦，她现在是一个照顾者了。她对工作的投入会减少。比阿特丽斯·阿兰达（Beatrice Aranda）和彼得·格里克（Peter Glick）进行了一项后续研究，其中探讨了女性是否有办法减轻或消除这种生育惩罚。事实证明，你没有什么可以消除它的办法，
but you can mitigate the motherhood penalty if you engage in behavior that is work devotional, where you never ever talk about your children and you constantly talk about your infinite capacity to take on more work. That, in my terminology, is covering. I'm thinking about the famous writer and activist Helen Keller. She was blind, but she was uncomfortable about being photographed from angles that showed her protruding eye. At one point, she later had her eyes replaced with glass eyes. And in fact, sometimes journalists would comment on how beautiful her eyes were.
但如果你表现出“工作奉献”的行为，从不谈论你的孩子，并不断谈论你承担更多工作的无限能力，你就可以减轻生育惩罚。用我的术语来说，这就是掩饰。我想到了著名作家兼活动家海伦·凯勒。她是个盲人，但她对从能拍到她突出眼睛的角度拍照感到不舒服。后来，她曾将眼睛换成了玻璃假眼。事实上，有时记者会评论她的眼睛有多么美丽。
That was an incredibly painful irony. And one of the richnesses of that anecdote that you just told is that if you were to ask somebody who the most famous disability rights advocate was, they would probably say Helen Keller. So you would imagine that she would lean heavily into her disability and her identity as a person who was blind, among other things. But the fact that she engaged in this cosmetic adjustment to appear more kind of normal and mainstream testifies to the fact that none of us ever evolve away from the force of these covering demands. I also want to make really clear that in all these instances, I'm not victim blaming.
那真是一个令人难以置信、痛苦的讽刺。你刚才讲的那个轶事的一个丰富之处在于，如果你问别人谁是最著名的残疾人权利倡导者，他们可能会说是海伦·凯勒。所以你会想象她会极力倾向于她的残疾和她作为盲人的身份。但她为了显得更正常、更主流而进行的这种外表上的调整，证明了我们当中没有任何人能够摆脱这些掩饰要求的力量。我还想明确指出的是，在所有这些情况下，我不是在指责受害者。
I'm not saying that, oh, FDR or Margaret Thatcher or Ben Kingsley or Helen Keller were self-hating or that they should have had more pride in their identity. I'm actually not interested in that at all. What I'm interested in is looking at the societal demand that in order to be seen as a full, equal, dignified member of society that you would need to downplay or edit these aspects of your identity. And that to me shows how much further we have to go in achieving full equality alongside
我不是在说，哦，FDR、玛格丽特·撒切尔、本·金斯利或海伦·凯勒是自我厌恶的，或者他们应该对自己的身份有更多的骄傲。我其实对这一点完全不感兴趣。我感兴趣的是审视社会的这种要求：为了被看作是一个完全的、平等的、有尊严的社会成员，你需要淡化或编辑你身份的这些方面。对我来说，这表明我们在实现与这些受污名化特征并存的完全平等这一目标上，还有很长的路要走。
these stigmatized traits. Are all sort of cosmetic interventions in some ways forms of covering? I mean, you know, from the very trivial about the bald man who has a comb over or, you know, the person who is dying their hair because their hair is turning gray, are these all examples of covering? I always answer that by saying, yes, there are all forms of covering, but not all forms of covering are problematic. So if I came to work alongside you and I was rapidly obnoxious to everybody in the workplace and you finally took me aside and said, Kenji, knock it off, you're driving everyone to distraction.
所有的外表干预在某种程度上都是一种掩饰吗？我的意思是，你知道的，从非常琐碎的秃顶男人的梳头发方式，或者，你知道的，因为头发变白而染发的人，这些都是掩饰的例子吗？我总是这样回答：是的，这些都是形式的掩饰，但并非所有形式的掩饰都是有问题的。如果我和你一起工作，我对工作场所里的每个人都极其讨厌，而你终于把我拉到一边对我说：贤治，别这样了，你把所有人都逼疯了。
And I said, well, wait a minute, Shankar, this is my authentic self. This is who I am. I just happen to be an incredibly obnoxious person. And you told me that you valued authenticity in the workplace, and so this is what you get. I would offer to you that that is covering, that you're requiring of me, but that a world in which I win that argument with you
我说，等等，香卡，这是我真实的自我。这就是我。我恰好是一个极其讨厌的人。而你告诉过我，你重视工作场所的真实性，所以这就是你得到的。我要对你说，那是掩饰，是你对我的要求，但如果我在与你的这场争论中获胜，
is a world in which none of us wanna live. So that means that there are some forms of covering that are at least neutral, but potentially even positive or even essential to the smooth functioning of a workplace or of a community. And that in turn pushes me to the harder question of, okay, if they're good forms of covering and bad forms of covering, how do are good forms of covering and bad forms of covering,
那个世界将是我们谁都不想生活的世界。这意味着有些形式的掩饰至少是中性的，甚至可能是潜在积极的，甚至对工作场所或社区的顺利运作至关重要。这反过来又将我推向了一个更难的问题，好吧，如果存在好的掩饰形式和坏的掩饰形式，
how do we distinguish between the good and bad forms? And to me, it's really about societal values. That's my answer of how we distinguish between the good and the bad forms. Because if you actually say to somebody, yes, you have to downplay your obnoxious personality, and I say, well, that's an impingement on my authenticity, you have a really good answer to that, right?
我们如何区分好与坏的形式？对我来说，这实际上关乎社会价值观。这就是我对我们如何区分好坏形式的回答。因为如果你对某人说，是的，你必须淡化你讨厌的个性，而我说，这侵犯了我的真实性，你对此有一个很好的回答，对吧？
Which is to say that we ask everybody to adhere to those norms and we understand that that might harm some people in their self-presentation more than others, but this is a tax that we're willing to exact in the name of the community because we think this is an utterly defensible value. On the other hand, if you said to me, well, you know, we believe in the inclusion of women in the workplace, but to go back to the earlier example, if you want to get a promotion,
那就是：我们要求每个人都遵守这些规范，并且我们理解这可能会在自我呈现方面对某些人造成比其他人更多的伤害，但这是我们愿意以社区的名义征收的税，因为我们认为这是一个完全站得住脚的价值观。另一方面，如果你对我说，你知道的，我们相信在工作场所包容女性，但回到先前的例子，如果你想获得晋升，
stop talking about your kids. If you say that to a woman and you wouldn't say that to a man, then that's a covering demand that I would have a problem with, because there the covering demand is not backed by a community value. And that's the inconsistency I want to challenge. When we come back, how covering complicates our understanding of what it means to belong. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
就别再谈论你的孩子了。如果你对一个女性这样说，而你不会对男性这样说，那么这就是一个我会有问题的掩饰要求，因为那里的掩饰要求没有社区价值观作支撑。这就是我想挑战的不一致之处。稍后回来，掩饰如何使我们对“归属”含义的理解变得复杂。您正在收听的是《隐秘大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Kenji Yoshino is a legal scholar at New York University. He is the author of Covering, The Hidden Assault on Our Civil Rights. Kenji, by the year 2001, you had long since come out as a gay man to your parents. They are of Japanese ancestry. But you found yourself having a tense discussion with them about an article about you that was about to be published in the New York Times. What was this article and how did this conversation with your parents unfold? The New York Times article was a profile on me and my work uncovering and Times article was a profile on me and my work on covering. And it was a very positive piece that might, in other circumstances, have been a cause
这里是《隐秘大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔。吉野贤治是纽约大学的一名法学学者。他是《掩饰：对我们民权的隐蔽攻击》一书的作者。贤治，到2001年的时候，你作为一名同性恋男子向父母出柜已经很久了。他们是日本血统。但你发现自己与他们就一篇即将发表在《纽约时报》上的关于你的文章进行了一场紧张的讨论。这篇文章是关于什么的，你和父母的这场对话是如何展开的？《纽约时报》的那篇文章是关于我和我关于掩饰的工作的简介文章，是一篇非常正面的文章。在其他情况下，这可能会成为
for celebration. But the article explicitly talked about the fact that I was an openly gay man, with my permission, you know, of course. And the thing that was challenging about this was that, again, my parents were the very first people that I had told that I was gay. But this was something different. This was being in the New York Times and being advertised as an openly gay person to the world.
庆祝的理由。但文章明确谈到了我是个公开的同性恋男性的事实，当然，这是在我的允许下。有挑战性的地方在于，我的父母是我告诉自己是同性恋的第一批人。但这有所不同。这是出现在《纽约时报》上，并向全世界宣传我是一个公开的同性恋者。
And so from their perspective, it was just a different level of publicity. And so they were essentially saying, it's fine for you to be out of the closet, but please don't draw this level of activism and advocacy to this role. So essentially, please downplay or cover. And the most poignant thing that my mother said to me was, you know, if this is published, then I won't be able to go home, meaning go home to Japan, because gay rights was in a much different place in Japan than it was in the United States. 監製組合 日本女性的女性 Your mother used a Japanese term in this conversation
因此，从他们的角度来看，这只是一种不同程度的宣传。所以他们本质上是在说，你出柜是可以的，但请不要把这种程度的积极行动和维权带到这个角色中来。所以本质上，请低调处理或掩饰。我母亲对我说过最辛酸的一句话是，你知道，如果这件事发表了，那我就回不了家了，意思是回日本，因为当时日本的同性恋权利状况与美国大不相同。監製組合 日本女性的女性 Your mother used a Japanese term in this conversation
that you didn't understand. What was this term, Kenji? This is a term that I believe would be unfamiliar to many Japanese people as well, because it was transliteration. So she said, we understand that you're gay, but why do you have to be a Jean d'Arc? And I was like, what?
你在这场对话中不理解的日语词汇。Kenji，这个词是什么？这是一个我认为对许多日本人来说也会感到陌生的词，因为它是音译。所以她说，我们理解你是同性恋，但你为什么非要当一个让·达尔克（Jean d’Arc）呢？我说，什么？
What is that? And she said, you know, the woman who heard voices. And I was like, what on earth are you talking about? Until the kind of penny dropped, and I realized that she was talking about Joan of Arc and the transliteration of Joan of Arc is Jean D'Arc. So essentially what she was saying is, it's fine for you to be gay, but why do you need to be a banner carrier for this identity? Why do you need to be an advocate or an activist with perhaps the implication of, and we all
那是什么？她说，你知道，就是那个听到声音的女人。我当时想，你在胡说八道什么？直到我恍然大悟，意识到她说的其实是圣女贞德（Joan of Arc），而圣女贞德的音译就是让·达尔克。所以她本质上是说，你是同性恋没关系，但你为什么非要做这种身份的旗手呢？你为什么非要做一个倡导者或活动家呢？这可能还暗示着，我们
know what happened to Joan of Arc in the end, so this doesn't land well for anybody. So in other words, live your life, be a gay person, but don't make it your cause. Exactly. And it was a version of the, it's fine for you to be a homosexual professional, but don't be a professional homosexual. Don't make this your cause. [♪ Piano music playing.
都知道贞德最后的结局，所以这对谁来说都不是一件好事。换句话说，过好你的人生，做一个同性恋者，但不要把它当成你的事业。没错。这其实是一种“你可以做一个同性恋专业人士，但不要做一个专业的同性恋者”的变体。不要把这当成你的事业。[♪ 钢琴曲响起。
One of the concerns that your parents had was not just the effects that this would have on them, but the effects that it would have on you. They were worried that you were going to get hate mail. I think about this all the time as a parent now where, you know, I have a, my parents are extraordinarily wonderful, supportive people. But since my husband and I have had our two kids, I think about this all the time as one of the most poignant things that they said to me. Because of course when you're a kid, you know, in your, I think I was in my 30s by that point, so not so much of a kid, you don't like to think of yourself as somebody whose parents need to look out for them in those ways.
你父母担心的不仅是这件事对他们产生的影响，还有它对你产生的影响。他们担心你会收到仇恨邮件。作为一个为人父母的人，我时常会想起这一点，你知道，我有，我的父母是非常好、非常支持我的人。但自从我和丈夫有了两个孩子后，我一直觉得这是他们对我说过的最辛酸的话之一。因为当你还是个孩子的时候，你知道，在你，我想我当时大概30多岁了，所以已经不算是个孩子了，你其实很不希望自己被视为那种需要父母在这方面为你操心的人。
So when they were saying, oh my gosh, you're going to get hate mail, you're going to get, you know, death threats, you're going to get this or that, I was just like, well, that's kind of my business. I'm fully able to take care of myself. I'm going into this with eyes wide open. So this is not something that you need to worry about. I'm much more concerned about what you're saying about yourselves and much less concerned about my own sort of risk profile.
所以当他们说，天哪，你会收到仇恨邮件，你会收到，你知道，死亡威胁，你会收到这个或那个时，我当时的反应是，嗯，这算是我的事。我完全有能力照顾好自己。我是带着清醒的认识面对这一切的。所以这不是你们需要担心的事情。我更担心的是你们对自己的看法，而远没有那么担心我自己的风险状况。
But now that I'm a father, I totally see where they are coming from, where in some ways there's nothing more painful than thinking, oh my gosh, my child could be the subject or object of hatred or hate mail or vitriol of some kind and it's not something that I as a parent can protect them from. So I think that's what they're trying to convey to me. So as a parent, I have made sure to reconnect with them on this particular point to say, you know, I really deeply appreciated that sentiment and probably was not able to hear it at the time because I was only seeing it through the lens of a child rather than the lens of a parent sort of desperate with worry
但现在我成了一位父亲，我完全理解他们的想法了。在某种程度上，没有什么比想到“天哪，我的孩子可能会成为仇恨、仇恨邮件或某种恶毒攻击的主体或目标，而作为父母的我却无法保护他”更令人痛苦的了。所以我想这正是他们试图向我传达的。因此，作为一名父亲，我确保就这个特定的观点重新与他们沟通，对他们说，你知道，我真的非常感激这种情感，可能当时由于我只能从孩子的视角来看待问题，而不是从一个为孩子担心到绝望的父母的视角来理解，所以当时没能体会到。
about their child. So you told your parents that you already got hate mail and your father was shocked and surprised by that, that you already were getting hate mail and your father was shocked and surprised by that that that you already were getting hate mail and And it struck you that in some ways this this detail that may have been connected to his own experience as a Young man from Japan who came to the United States in the 1950s. Tell me what went through your mind at that point Kenji. I can only speculate here because this is something that I don't really know because it's not really something that is talked about openly in our family.
所以你告诉你的父母你已经收到过仇恨邮件了，你父亲对此感到震惊和惊讶，你居然已经收到过仇恨邮件了，你父亲对此感到震惊和惊讶，你居然已经收到过仇恨邮件了，而且让你感到触动的是，在某种程度上，这个细节可能与他自己作为一个在20世纪50年代来到美国的日本年轻人的经历有关。Kenji，请告诉我，那时你脑海里在想些什么。我在这里只能进行推测，因为这是我并不是很清楚的事情，因为在我们家里，这其实并不是一件会被公开谈论的事情。
But I can only imagine what anti-Japanese sentiment must have been like in the middle of the 20th century when he came over very, very young, you know, after he graduated from high school and was going to college. So if you think about this era after World War II, the anti-Japanese sentiment must have been enormous. So I do sometimes think that they thought, well, we suffered through all of this because we had to, but we thought that you were going to grow up in a kindler, gentler America with regard to race, and so you would be able to kind of write your own ticket.
但我完全可以想象，在20世纪中期他非常年轻的时候来到这里时，反日情绪会有多高涨，你知道，那是他高中毕业准备上大学的时候。所以如果你想想二战后的这段时期，反日情绪一定是非常巨大的。所以我有时确实觉得他们在想，我们承受这一切是因为我们别无选择，但我们曾以为你会在一个对种族问题更友善、更温和的美国长大，这样你就能掌握自己的命运。
But now you are embracing or identifying with this identity that is so stigmatized that you're essentially going to have to go through all of this prejudice that we went through just on a different dimension. Your parents had a view of assimilation that is quite different than yours. Your dad sort of describes himself as sort of the stereotypical, you know, success story
但现在你却在拥抱或认同这样一个饱受污名化的身份，以至于你基本上也不得不经历我们经历过的所有这些偏见，只不过是在另一个维度上。你父母对同质化（同化）的看法与你的看法截然不同。你父亲某种程度上将自己描述为美国梦的典型成功故事，以及同化价值的受益者。Kenji，请告诉我，你的同化观是如何变得与你的父母不同的。我想说的是，它们确实不同，但我也觉得，我能持有与他们不同的观点，在很大程度上要归功于他们。为了解释这一点，我认为我父亲对同化的态度是这样的，你知道，在美国我就做100%的美国人，在日本我就做100%的日本人。所以他深深地融入了当地，从一个来到这个国家的年轻移民，最终以哈佛大学商学院终身教授的身份走完了他的一生。
of the American dream and the value of assimilation. Tell me how your views about assimilation have come to differ from your parents Kenji. I want to say that they differ, but I also feel that I owe them an incredible amount for the fact that I can hold a position that's different from theirs. So to explain this, I think my dad's attitude towards assimilation was this, you know, I'm going to be 100% American in America and 100% Japanese in Japan. And so he was deeply assimilated and went from being a young immigrant to this country to ending his life as a, you know, a charred professor at Harvard in the business school.
所以他有着非常传奇的职业生涯。我真的觉得，我确实认为他觉得这种能够在两种文化之间无缝切换的能力正是他想要做的事情。而我的观点是，我其实并不想进行这种切换。我不想在任何一个国家被同化。就像我想做我自己一样。无论我身在何处，我都想成为同一个真正的人。如果周围的环境对真实的我充满敌意，那么我就不会住在那里。
So he had a very storied career. And I really did think, I do think that he felt that this ability to code switch seamlessly between the two cultures was what he wanted to do. And my view was I actually don't want to code switch. I don't want to assimilate in either country. Like I want to be myself. I want to be the same person regardless of where I am. And to the extent that environment is inhospitable to the person that I really am, then I will not live there.
我不会在那里工作，对吧？所以我想我之所以对把日本作为居住或工作地点的热情降温，就是因为我觉得LGBTQIA+群体的权利状况与美国相比处于一个不同的阶段。但这两种经历是交织在一起的、密不可分的，对吧？因为如果不曾有他的人生，我想我是不可能过上我现在这样享有特权的生活的。
I will not work there, right? So I think one of the reasons why I cooled on Japan as a place to live or work was that I just felt like LGBTQIA-plus rights were just in a different place than they were in the United States. But the two stories are intricate with each other, right? Because I don't think that I could have the life that I am privileged enough to live right now if he hadn't lived his life.
正因为他实际创造了特权和优势的条件——无论是教育、家庭熏陶、自信心还是其他什么，才让我能够过上现在的生活。这真的很触动人心，Kenji，因为我觉得同化的概念，也就是熔炉的概念——仿佛我们把自己的身份抛在脑后，忘记了我们曾是爱尔兰人、犹太人，或者说（同性恋）同性恋、黑人，我们来到美国，然后我们都变成了同一种新东西，
So that he actually created the conditions of privilege and advantage, whether that was educational or familial nurture or self-confidence or what have you, that allowed me to live the life that I'm living now. It's striking Kenji because I feel like the idea of assimilation, the idea of the melting pot, like we leave our identities behind, we forget that we were Irish or Jewish or, you know, gay or black, that we come to America and then we all become this new thing,
那就是美国人。我认为这被视为一种价值，你知道的，一个重要的理想。但你在某种程度上也指出了同化的阴暗面，能谈谈这个吗？我当然可以。所以，是的，我其实看到了熔炉理想的吸引力，看到了我们需要政治学家罗伯特·帕特南（Robert Putnam）所说的“桥接资本”的那种需求，即那些把我们所有人凝聚在一起的、超越性的身份认同，比如作为美国人的身份认同。
which is an American. I think that's held up as being a value, you know, an important ideal. You're pointing in some ways to the dark side of assimilation, can you talk about that a moment? I certainly can. So, yes, I actually see the allure of the melting pot ideal, of the idea that we need sort of what the political scientist
但罗伯特·帕特南也谈到了“束缚资本”的重要性，他说，如果我们完全融化进大熔炉里，你知道，那也是个问题。而我们需要向社会提供的资本之一，就是那种仅在社群内部建立起来的资本。
Robert Putnam calls bridging capital, of these supervening identities that sort of bring us all together, like the identity of being an American. But Robert Putnam also talks about the importance of bonding capital, and he says, if we melt totally into the pot, you know, that's a problem too. And part of the capital that we need to offer to society
比如LGBT社群，或者亚裔美国人社群，成为这些社群的一部分实际上丰富了整个社会，而不是使其贫瘠。所以我们不能向任何一个方向过度倾斜。一个过度强调桥接的人会说，你们为什么总是不停地谈论你们的身份？就像，你们应该直接把它抛在脑后一样。
is the kind of capital we build only internal to communities. So the LGBT community, for example, or the Asian American community, being a part of those communities actually enriches the whole rather than impoverishing it. So we can't be tilted over one wing in one direction or the other. So someone who bridges too much would say, why do you keep banging on about your identity? Like, you should just leave it behind.
你唯一的身份就是美国人的身份，或者是世界公民、人类或诸如此类的身份。而我相信，作为人类，我们的共同点多于不同点，保持这一点清晰可见是非常重要的，但这不能以牺牲我们所保留的所有差异为代价，也不能以牺牲这种感觉为代价：我们身上有些部分理所当然地拒绝融入那个大熔炉。并且我属于美国国内那些不同于这种泛泛的美国人概念的次级社群，
The only identity that you have is this identity as American or this identity as a citizen of the world or as a human being or what have you. And I believe that we have more in common than not as human beings and it's really important to keep that steadily visible, but not at the expense of understanding all the differences that we also retain and this kind of sense that there are parts of us that rightly refuse to melt into the pot. And that I belong to sub communities within the United States that
当你告诉我融入熔炉时，这总是意味着，边缘化群体正在同化并顺应统治阶层设定的规范。因此，如果过于迅速或绝对化地说“让我们全都拥抱熔炉理想”，会产生真正的、不平等的效应，因为有些人因为塑造了这种理想，所以对这种理想感到更加舒适，而另一些人则被告知去融入其中。据我所知，你在企业环境中进行过调查，发现“掩饰”（covering）
are different from this kind of generic idea of the American and when you tell me to melt into the pot, that always means, right, that the marginalized group is assimilating and conforming to the norms set by the dominant group. So it has really an egalitarian effects to too quickly or categorically say, let's all embrace the melting pot ideal, because some people are much more comfortable with that ideal because they've shaped that ideal than the others who are being told to melt into it. I understand that you have conducted surveys in corporate environments that find that covering
会负面影响个人的自我意识，并削弱他们对组织的承诺。我在进行这方面的实证研究时，非常依赖我在管理咨询公司德勤（Deloitte）的杰出同事们。但我大约在2012年接到了一通电话，我想大多数学者接到这样的电话都会大吃一惊，他们说：“看，这种‘掩饰’的概念是一场变革，但除非你有数据，否则我们这个世界里没有人会相信你说的任何话。”
negatively impacts individual sense of self and diminishes their commitment to their organizations. I really lean on my wonderful colleagues at the management consultancy Deloitte for the empirical work on this. But I got the kind of call that I think most academics are kind of gobsmacked to receive sometime in 2012, where they said, look, this idea of covering is a game changer, but no one in our world is going to believe anything that you
“你不是实证主义者，我们是。所以让我们做个调查，弄清楚‘掩饰’的发生率和影响是什么。”所以我当然答应了，调查结果有力地支持了这一假设，即人们正在以非常高的比例进行“掩饰”。我们发现，总体上有61%的人报告了“掩饰”行为，
say unless you have data. You're not an empiricist, we are. So let's do a survey and figure out, you know, what the incidence and impact of covering is. And so I of course said yes, the survey came back to robustly support the hypothesis that people were covering at a very high rate. We found 61% of people overall reported covering,
而在那61%的人中，根据“掩饰”维度的不同，有60%到73%的人表示，这在一定程度上极大地损害了他们的自我认知。据我了解，几年前你曾面临过一个时刻，将你对同化的所有复杂观点都激发了出来。这与纽约大学（NYU）的一份优厚工作邀约有关。Kenji，能讲讲那个故事吗？这是2008年的事，其实这是我最喜欢讲的故事之一，因为我认为它赋予了所有参与其中的人以尊严，或者说向所有参与其中表达了敬意，因为这是一个关于改变和成长的故事。
and of that 61%, 60 to 73%, depending on the axis of covering, said that this was somewhat too extremely detrimental to their sense of self. I understand that you faced a moment a number of years ago that brought all of your complex views about assimilation into play. It had to do with a wonderful job offer from NYU. Tell me that story, Kenji. This comes from 2008, and it's actually one of my favorite stories to tell because I think it ennobles everybody who took part in it, or honors everybody who took part in it, because it's a story of change and growth.
所以在2008年，我和我丈夫正考虑组建家庭，我们决定必须在同一个城市才能做到这一点。所以我申请了纽约的学校，很幸运地得到了一些offer，接着招聘季就开始了。纽约大学当时的院长里奇·里瓦斯（Ricky Revesz）联系了我，他说，我们知道你在耶鲁大学有一个对你而言非常珍贵的教席，
So in 2008, my husband and I are thinking about starting a family and we decide that we need to be in the same city to do that. So I applied to schools in New York, was fortunate enough to get some offers and then the recruitment season began. So the then Dean of NYU, Ricky Rivas, reached out to me and he said, we know you have a chair at Yale
即吉多·卡拉布雷西法学教授讲座教席（Guido Calabresi Professorship of Law）。它是以我在第二巡回上诉法院为其担任书记员的那位法官命名的，他也是法学院的前院长和我的伟大导师。顺便说一句，他不是给我那个建议的导师。接着他说，我们搜寻了现有的教席，想找一个对你而言具有同等重要意义的教席。
that's very dear to you, which is Guido Calabresi Professorship of Law. It was named after the judge for whom I clerked on the Second Circuit and the former Dean of the Law School and a great mentor of mine. Not by the way, the mentor who gave me that advice. And then he said, we've scoured our existing chairs to find one that would be comparable in terms of its significance to you.
但我们找不到。于是我们采取了不同寻常的举措，筹集了500万美元来设立一个新的教席。这个教席将以你的名字命名，以表彰你在宪法和民权交叉领域的贡献，我们将把它命名为厄尔·沃伦宪法学教授讲座教席（Earl Warren Professorship of Constitutional Law）。尚卡尔（Shankar），我体内每一个想要讨好别人的细胞都想接受这个教席，它凝聚了世上所有的善意。但我当时 literally（简直）刚刚写完、刚写完关于“掩饰”的书，我知道如果不加任何抗议就接受这个教席，
We couldn't find one. And so we took the extraordinary step of raising $5 million to endow a new chair. And that chair is going to be named to honor your contributions at the intersection of constitutional law and civil rights, and we're going to name it the Earl Warren Professorship of Constitutional Law. And every people-pleasing bone in my body, Shankar, wanted to take the chair, which had been given with all the goodwill in the world. But I had literally written, finished writing the book on covering, and I knew that it would
将是一种形式的“掩饰”。为什么？所以我对里奇说，里奇，我不能接受那个教席。他很震惊，我能看出他甚至有点恼火，他说，为什么不能？我希望你明白这里面付出了多少工作。我说，是的，我知道。
be a form of covering to accept the chair without some kind of protest. Why? So I said, Ricky, like, I can't take that chair. And he was astonished, and I could tell a little bit annoyed, and he said, why on earth not? I hope you understand how much work went into this. And I said, yes, I'm aware of that.
但正如你可能知道的，我是日裔。而且你可能也知道，作为加州总检察长，厄尔·沃伦曾主管将10万多名具有日本血统的人关押在集中营里，且没有经过任何正当程序或刑事指控。哇。我说，我不能用一个如此羞辱我族群的人的名字来接受荣誉。于是他把这个教席收回了，他立刻明白了，并说，请不要做出任何突然的举动，
But as you may know, I'm of Japanese descent. And as you may know, as Attorney General of California, Earl Warren superintended the interment of over 100,000 people of Japanese ancestry without any due process or criminal charges. Wow. And I said, I can't be honored with the name of an individual who has so dishonored my people. So he took that away, he immediately got it, and he said, please don't make any sudden
你知道，不要去另一所学校，我三天后给你回电话。三天后，他回电话说，我为你准备了一个新教席。我说洗耳恭听，我全神贯注。他说，我们想为你提供“首席大法官厄尔·沃伦宪法学教授讲座教席”。而这一次轮到我有点恼火了，而且绝对是震惊，因为我想，等等，我三天前刚刚拒绝了厄尔·沃伦教授讲座教席。你现在居然把“首席大法官”几个字加在它前面，然后又把它抛回给我，好像这是一个新教席一样。
movements, you know, don't go to another school, I'll call you back in three days. And three days later, he called back and he said, I have a new chair for you. And I said, lay it on me, I'm all ears. And he said, we want to offer you the chief justice Earl Warren professorship of constitutional law. And this time I was the one who was a little bit annoyed and certainly astonished because I thought, well, wait a minute, I just rejected the Earl Warren professorship three days ago. You're now tacking the word chief justice to the front of it and flipping it back to
所以本质上，你觉得我有多蠢？这到底是怎么回事？他说，请听我把话说完。在我们上次对话之后的几天里，我读了一本厄尔·沃伦的传记。他说，作为美国最高法院首席大法官，他曾写下诸如《布朗诉教育委员会案》（Brown v. Board of Education）或使美国跨种族婚姻合法的《洛文诉弗吉尼亚州案》（Loving v. Virginia）这样具有典范意义的判决，而他职业生涯中最懊悔的事情就是关押日本人。所以他说，考虑到
me as if this were a new chair. So essentially, how stupid do you think I am? Like, what's going on here? And he said, please hear me out. In the days since our last conversation, I've read a biography of Earl Warren. And he said, as Chief Justice of the United States Supreme Court, who wrote canonical opinions like Brown v. Board of Education or Loving vs. Virginia, which legalized interracial marriage in the United States, that the thing he most regretted about his career was the internment of the Japanese. So he said, you know, given
你对民权的承诺，以及你对多元化和包容性的承诺，我认为你毕生的工作就是引领人们走过这段旅程，或经历一个关于理解“作为人类究竟有多少种不同且合理的方式”的成熟曲线。他说，既然厄尔·沃伦在有生之年能够在通往那个目标的道路上走得那么远，我们实际上认为，保留他的名字将是你工作力量的一个绝妙象征，但你保留的是他在完成那段旅程时（而不是开始时）所持有的头衔。所以我说，里奇，那个教席我接受。
your commitment to civil rights and given your commitments to diversity and inclusion, I take your life work to be taking people along this journey or a maturity curve of understanding how many different valid ways there are to be a human being. And he said, given that Earl Warren was able to travel so far along that path in a single lifetime, we actually think that it would be a wonderful emblem of the power of your work to hold his name, but to hold the title that he held when he was completing rather than beginning that journey. So I said, Ricky, that chair I can take.
因此，我今天是以首席大法官厄尔·沃伦宪法学教授的身份在发言。稍后回来，我们将探讨揭露我们真实身份、并帮助他人做到这一点的技巧。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。法律学者肯吉·吉野（Kenji Yoshino）花费了数十年时间思考人们如何掩饰自己的身份，以顺应来自周围人真实或想象的压力。他也花了很多很多时间思考我们如何在更多的时间里做更多真实的自己。肯吉，你有时会听到一些人的声音，
And so I am speaking today as the Chief Justice Earl Warren, Professor of Constitutional Law. When we come back, techniques to uncover our true identities and help others do the same. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Legal scholar Kenji Yoshino has spent decades thinking about how people mask their identities in order to conform to both real and imagined pressures from those around them. He's also thought a lot about how we can be more of ourselves more of the time. Kenji, you sometimes hear from people who
他们并不同意你的观点。他们会说，你知道的，你可能是个同性恋男性，觉得有隐藏的必要，但我是个直男，我也觉得有隐藏的必要。也许是因为我超重了、老了，或者酒喝得太多了。也许我患有某种被污名化的精神疾病。也许我只是害羞。肯吉，能跟我讲讲这些遭遇吗？肯吉 德勤（Deloitte）研究中最引人注目的发现之一就是，我们发现45%的直男白人报告了“掩饰”行为。我想我的同事们觉得这真的很令人惊讶，而我却一点也不觉得惊讶，
disagree with you. They say, you know, you may be a gay man and feel the need to hide, but I'm straight and I feel the need to hide too. Maybe it's because I'm overweight or elderly or drink too much. Maybe I have a mental illness that's stigmatized. Maybe I'm just shy. Tell me about these encounters, Kenji. Kenji This is one of the most remarkable findings of the Deloitte study, which is that we found that 45% of straight white men reported covering. And I think my colleagues found that really surprising, and I didn't find it surprising
因为我在出版这本书后的很多年里，白人男性经常来找我，对我说：“这些都是我不得不掩饰的身份。”所以如果说有什么让我惊讶的话，那就是这个数字居然这么低。但直男白人报告的最主要的“掩饰”方式是年龄、社会经济地位或背景、导师或身体疾病或残疾、宗教以及退伍军人身份。这个事实极其重要——社会中表面上最具特权群体的多数人竟然也在进行“掩饰”——这表明这确实是一个普遍的现象。
at all because I had spent, you know, many years after publishing the book where white men would come to me and say, here are all the identities that I have to cover. So if anything, I was surprised that that number was so low. But the dominant ways in which straight white men reported covering were things like age, socioeconomic status or background, mentor or physical illness or disability, religion, and veteran status. And the thing that's so important about the fact that a plurality of the ostensibly most empowered group in society is covering is that it shows that this is truly a universal phenomenon.
我回到我之前说过的话，也就是说，如果你在任何方面处于主流之外，你就会被要求进行“掩饰”。而且很多时候，你会将此体验为一种伤害。因此，无论我们拥有多少主流特征，我们总会拥有一些非主流特征。一旦你看到了这一点，这就真的不再是一个关于“我们对他们”、或者“边缘化群体对非边缘化群体”的项目，而真正成为了一个关于真实性的普遍项目，
I go back to what I said earlier, which is to say if you're outside of the mainstream in any way, you are going to be asked to cover. And oftentimes you're going to experience that as a harm. So no matter how many dominant characteristics we hold, we're going to hold some non-dominant ones. And once you see that, then this really becomes a project not about us versus them, or marginalized groups versus non-marginalized groups, but really a universal project
它促使我们去思考：如果我们所有人都能被赋予权力，多做一点自我，世界会是什么样子，我们各自的社群又会是什么样子。我也在思考一些纯粹的行为层面的事情。你知道，也许我是一个害羞的人。你知道，也许我是一个悲伤的人，而且害羞和悲伤在职场中并不受赞赏。如果我表现得内向或沮丧，我就不会被视为一个有前途的新星、一个有潜力的员工。因此，我感到有必要掩饰我正在经历的一切。我很高兴你这么说，因为人们经常会说，好吧，你知道，这是一种虚假的对等，你的害羞和我的种族是不一样的。我绝
of authenticity and thinking about what the world might look like, what our individual communities might look like if we were all empowered to be a little bit more ourselves. I'm thinking also just of behavioral things. You know, perhaps I'm a shy person. You know, perhaps I am a sad person and perhaps being shy and being sad are not celebrated in the workplace. I'm not going to be seen as an up-and-comer, as a promising employee if I'm seen to be retiring or depressed. And so I feel the need to cover up what I'm going through. I am so glad that you said that because oftentimes people say, well, you know, that's a kind of false equivalence of, you know, your shyness is not the same as my race. And I, by no
没有说它们是一样的。在种族问题上，存在着一种长期累积的从属历史，而内向性格则没有。但是，尽管如此，如果我们看看内向，我这辈子最喜欢的书之一就是苏珊·凯恩（Susan Cain）的《安静》（Quiet）。副标题是《内向性格的竞争力：在这个喋喋不休的世界里》（The Power of Introverts in a World That Can Stopp Talking）。她谈到，根据我们对美国社会的定义，内向者大约占三分之一，并且不断被要求扭曲自己，去躺在普洛克路斯忒斯（Procrustes）的外向性铁床之上。以至于我们在美国社会拥有这样一种外向者理想，它声称一个真正的
means, I'm saying that they are the same. There's a kind of sedimented history of subordination in the case of race that there isn't in the case of introversion. But, you know, all that said, if we look at introversion, one of my favorite books of all time is Susan Cain's Quiet. The subtitle is The Power of Introverts in a World That Can't Stop Talking. And she talks about how people who are introverts are about one-third, according to our definition of American society, and are constantly being asked to torque themselves to lie down on the Procrustian bed of extroversion. So that we have this extrovert ideal in American society that says that a true
领导者应该是一种喜欢拍人后背、长袖善舞、富有个人魅力的、你知道的那种人，而内向者如果想要在生活中有所成就，就真的需要适应这种模式。她从道德和政策的角度提出了非常令人信服的理由，说明为什么不该如此，她指出人们天生就是内向或外向的。即使在我们自己的历史上，如果你回溯过去，我们最伟大的领导者——比如詹姆斯·麦迪逊（James Madison）或亚伯拉罕·林肯（Abraham Lincoln）——也都是典型的内向者。所以这种认为“内向与成为领导者之间存在矛盾”的观点，完全被我们自己的历史所反驳。
leader is a kind of back-slapping, glad-handing, charismatic, you know, person and that the introvert really needs to adapt to that modality if they want to get anywhere in life. And she makes a really compelling kind of moral and policy-based case for why this shouldn't be the case, saying that people are just naturally introverted or extroverted. And even in our own history, if you go back in time, our greatest leaders like James Madison or Abraham Lincoln were classic introverts. So this idea that there's something inconsistent between being an introvert and being a leader is something that our own history completely belies.
因此，我认为非常重要的一点是，要对这些新兴的身份类别保持警惕。如果在某个特定的时间点，你问：“内向怎么办？”或者“抑郁或心理健康问题怎么办？”其他人可能会说：“那些是边缘性的或附带现象的身份。”这跟种族或性别无关。
So one of the things that I think is really important is to just keep a weather eye out for these emerging identity categories where if you say, you know, at a certain point of time, oh, what about introversion or what about depression or mental health issues, that, you know, other people might say, well, those are kind of tangential or epiphenomenal identities. This is not about sort of race or gender.
因此我选择忽略它。我的分析则会截然不同，它会表现为对这些身份的一种好奇，会说：“请告诉我更多，”并像我们之前讨论的那样去追问：当要求人们改变或掩饰其底层身份时，站在对立面的人究竟能有什么可能的正当理由？因此，如果我说你必须掩饰，因为领导者必须是外向的，所以你应该对你的内向身份感到羞耻
And so therefore I'm gonna ignore it. My analysis would be quite different, which would be a kind of curiosity about those identities to say, please tell me more, right? And to ask, as we were discussing earlier, what possible justification could an individual have on the other side of asking people to change or cover the underlying identity. So if I say you have to cover because leaders are just extroverts and so you should be ashamed
或将其淡化，再次强调，我们的历史推翻了这种假设。所以，成为领导者和作为内向者之间并没有任何不一致。我们应该赞美那些伟大的演说家领导者，但我们也应该赞美那些伟大的倾听者领导者。同样对于抑郁症，我非常高兴我们终于在全国范围内展开了我们急需进行的心理健康对话。
or downplay your introverted identity, again, our history abends that assumption. So there's nothing inconsistent with being a leader and being an introvert. We should celebrate leaders who are great orators, but we should also celebrate leaders who are great listeners. Similarly with depression, I'm so delighted that we're finally having the mental health conversation
我意识到我们还处于初期阶段，但我感觉我们正在以一种在我有生之年从未有过的方式来谈论它。所以我认为这是一个非常积极的发展。在这里也可能有人会说：“哦，但在这里我们想要改变这种根本状况。我们不希望你抑郁。”
nationally that we need to have. I realize we're still in early days, but I feel like we were talking about it in a way that we have not talked about it in my lifetime. So I view that to be a really positive development. Here too, it might be like, oh, but here we want to change the underlying condition. We don't want you to be depressed.
所以我们希望你寻求帮助或寻找药物。但对我来说，这也是一场关于真实与坦诚的争论，因为你该如何更好地帮助那个正在与抑郁症做斗争的人呢？你是通过对他说“假装你没有抑郁”来帮助他？还是通过对他说“我们承认你很抑郁，我们不会因为你抑郁而看低你。如果你需要帮助，这里就是你可以获得帮助的地方，我们就在你身边”？当你考虑到诸如成瘾之类的事情，或者成瘾触及这个国家如此众多生命的方式时，你知道，它触及了富人和穷人、黑人和白人、每一个社会经济群体以及每一个人口统计群体的生命。
So we want you to find help or you want to find medication. But that too, to me, seems like an argument about authenticity and candor, because how are you going to help the person who is struggling with depression more? Are you going to help them by saying, pretend not to be depressed? Or are you going to say, we acknowledge that you are depressed, we do not think any less of you because you're depressed. If you need help, this is where you can get help. We're here for you. this is where you can get help. We're here for you. When I think about something like addiction, for example, or the ways in which addiction has
但显然，今天社会对成瘾有着巨大的污名化，职场中以及社交生活中都存在着巨大的掩饰成瘾的需求。正因如此，我真的希望人们将这个“揭露”的项目视为一场打击那些毫无道德基础或稳健政策依据的污名化的运动。
touched so many lives in this country, you know, it has touched the lives of people who are rich and poor and black and white and, you know, every socioeconomic group and every demographic group. But clearly there's a huge stigma about addiction today and there's a huge demand to cover up, you know, addictions in the workplace, but also in social life. And exactly that way, I really want people to think about this project of uncovering as a project of fighting stigmas that have no basis in morality or in sound policy.
如果我们消除针对那些与成瘾作斗争的个人的指责和羞辱方法，让他们能够开诚布公地谈论这些，我们就会做得好得多，因为这样我们实际上才有希望识别他们并提供他们所需的帮助，而不是假装问题不存在，或者用羞辱将他们推向更糟糕的成瘾或抑郁的恶性循环中。肯吉，我听到的你的论点是，在某种程度上，“掩饰”是一个具有统一性的事业，甚至可能是一种普遍的民权斗争。我完全这样认为。这正是我想要表达的。
We are going to do so much better if we eliminate the blaming, shaming approach towards individuals who are struggling with that addiction and to let them speak frankly about them, because then we actually have some prayer of identifying them and giving them the help that they need, rather than, you know, pretending the problem doesn't exist or shaming them into even worse cycles or spirals of addiction or depression. Kenji, what I hear you arguing is that covering in some ways is a unifying cause, perhaps even sort of a universal civil rights struggle. I entirely believe that. That's exactly what I'm trying to say.
我总是想起马斯洛（Maslow）的需求层次理论，他谈到了作为人类，为了能够进入下一层需求之前，我们需要满足的需求。所以最底层显然是食物和水，然后是住所。但在此之上的那一个，却相当令人惊讶，那就是归属感——我们迫切需要归属感，觉得我们属于某个社群或社会，否则我们将无法蓬勃发展。
I always think about Maslow's hierarchy of needs where he talks about the needs that we need to get met as human beings before we can go to the next level of needs. So that the very bottom is like food and water, obviously, and then there's shelter. But then the one beyond that, which is quite surprising, is belonging, that we really need to belong and feel like we belong to a community or a society, or we're just going to be unable to thrive.
而我的“掩饰”项目，实际上正试图确保人们找到一条通往归属感的途径，正如我认为的那样，它必须建立在真实性的基础之上。所以冒着听起来有些感伤的风险，我将再次回到我伟大的父母身边，说他们在我成长过程中经常对我说：“我们爱你。”但我相信了这份爱，却不相信“你”，因为我呈现给他们的“你”并不是真正的我。所以我想，如果我向你们出柜说我是同性恋，
And my project of covering is really trying to make sure that people find a pathway to belonging that is based, as I think it has to be, on authenticity. So at the risk of sounding sentimental, I will again go back to my wonderful parents and to say that they constantly were saying to me as I was growing up, we love you. But I trusted the love, but I didn't trust the you, because the you that I was presenting to them was not the real me. So I thought, if I come out to you as gay,
我不知道你们是否还会爱我。直到我出柜之后，当他们说“我们爱你”（并且他们至今仍在这么说）时，我才真正相信了他们。这种想法——你可以用一种不那么感伤、更日常的词汇来构筑它——如果我对尚卡尔说，我尊重你，但你身上有些事情并没有完全向我坦白，你可能会相信这份尊重，但你可能不会相信“你”。
I don't know if you will still love me. And it was only after I came out that I trusted them when they said, as they continue to say, we love you. And so that idea, and you could frame it in less kind of sentimental, more daily terms, if I say, Shankar, I respect you, but there's something about yourself that you're not fully disclosing to me, you might trust the respect, but you might not trust the you.
你可能会想，这种尊重其实是给予了我呈现给世界的某种虚构的我，而不是真正的我。只有当我为你创造了条件，让你能够完全展现真实自我时，我才能说我尊重你，而你才能同时信任这份尊重和真实的你。所以对我来说，这个项目是一个关于我们如何真正实现归属感的项目。
You might think, well, that respect attaches to some kind of fictional me that I'm presenting to the world rather than my real self. And it's only when I give you, right, the conditions to be fully authentic that I can say I respect you and you can trust the respect and the you. So for me, this project is a project about saying, how do we actually achieve belonging?
如果那个产生归属感的人并不是真正的你，你就根本无法获得任何形式的归属感。所以如果我在极端情况下说，比如，帕斯（Paz）是个直男，每个人都说：“哦，肯吉是个好人，我们接受他，他属于这个社群，”我永远不会相信那种归属感，因为你们接纳的那个人根本不是我。那只是为了被接纳而创造出来的我的一个摹本。所以我并没有给这个社群一个机会去接受真实的我。所以我意识到这可能会让人感到非常害怕和充满风险，但这种想法——我可以
You don't achieve any kind of belonging if the person who belongs is not really you. So if I say in an extreme case, like, Paz is a straight person and everyone says, oh, Kenji's a great guy, we accept him, he belongs in this community, I'm never going to trust that sense of belonging because the person you've included is not me. It's some facsimile of me that I've created in order to be included. So I've not given the community the chance to accept me for who I really am. So I realize it can feel very scary and very risky, but this idea that I could
真正对我的社群说：“这才是真实的我，”然后社群回应说：“而且你以这样的身份属于这里。”只有在那时，我才能真正相信那种归属感。你说过，分享“揭露”（uncovering）故事有几种不同的方式。其中一种是你所谓的“鲜明叙事”（distinct storytelling）。肯吉，这是什么？鲜明叙事有点像我一直在做的这件事，
actually say to my community, this is who I truly am, and then the community responds by saying, and you belong as you. That's when I can really trust that sense of belonging. You say that there are a couple of different ways that stories of uncovering can be shared. One is what you call distinct storytelling. What is this, Kenji? Distinct storytelling is kind of what I've been doing
尚卡尔，在这个美妙的交流中，在多个节点上，当我谈到一个故事时，比如：哦，我当时在争取终身教授职位，有人告诉我，如果我想拿到终身教授职位，就必须淡化我的性取向，或者如果我想拿到终身教授职位，就不要写同性恋相关的话题。或者当我被提供这个教席时，我不得不争论是否要发声。就像那些你被要求进行“掩饰”、但你拒绝了“掩饰”的要求，并且在另一端以比你选择缩头乌龟、一走了之要强大得多的姿态走出来的那些时刻。这些就是我所说的鲜明叙事。
at multiple points in this wonderful exchange, Shankar, which is when I talk about a story like, oh, I was on the tenure track and I was told to downplay my sexual orientation if I wanted tenure or not write on gay topics if I wanted tenure. Or when I was offered this chair and I had to debate whether or not to speak up. Like those moments where you are being asked to cover and you rejected the covering demand and you came out of it on the other side much stronger than you would have been if you had ducked your head and gone away. Those are what I'm calling distinct stories.
它们是独立的场景、故事、轶事，向人们阐明了真实性的力量。为了把话说完，想象一下，如果我没有对院长进行反击，就接受了那个听起来很相似的“厄尔·沃伦宪法学教授讲座教席”。我向你保证，每次我被介绍时——无论是在这次采访中还是在其他地方——我的内心都会涌起一股羞耻感：那是人生中我本来应该为自己挺身而出却没有这么做的时刻。
They are set pieces, they're stories, they're anecdotes that just illustrate to people the power of authenticity. So just to land the plane on this, imagine if I had accepted the very similar sounding chair of the Earl Warren Professorship of Constitutional Law without pushing back on my dean. I can guarantee you that every time I was introduced, whether on this interview or elsewhere, I would have had like a wave of shame of like, that was a moment in my life where I should have stuck up for myself and I did it.
而现在我却在这个余生中都被这个头衔套牢了。然而，正因为我在那个时刻为自己挺身而出，并促成了头衔的更改，这看起来可能是一件微不足道的小事，但我可以告诉你，每次我被介绍为“首席大法官厄尔·沃伦宪法学教授”时，我对它的感觉就完全不同了。我记得那是把我的真实性带到桌面上的一次经历，而
And here I am stuck with this title for the rest of my life. Whereas because I stuck up for myself in that moment and got that title change, it may seem like a very small thing, but I can tell you that every time I'm introduced as the Chief Justice or a Warren Professor of Constitutional Law, then I feel completely differently about it. I remember that that was a time in which I brought my authenticity to the table and the
对方也以实际行动回应了对这种真实性的尊重。你还谈到了一种叫做“弥散叙事”（diffuse storytelling）的东西。什么是弥散叙事，肯吉？是的，我们把弥散与……这里说的“我们”是指我在德勤的同事，以及我在纽约大学的杰出同事克里斯蒂娜·约瑟夫（Christina Joseph）和大卫·格拉斯哥（David Glasgow）。我们在鲜明叙事和弥散叙事之间划清界限，因为当我们谈到
other side rose to the occasion of honoring that authenticity. You also talk about something called diffuse storytelling. What is diffuse storytelling, Kenji? Yeah, we contrast diffuse, and by we, I mean my colleagues at Deloitte and my wonderful colleagues here at NYU, Christina Joseph and David Glasgow. We draw a distinction between distinct storytelling and diffuse storytelling because when we talk about
“分享你的故事”以及讲故事对于建立“揭露”人才的文化的重要性时，我认为人们会觉得他们需要有一个独立的场景，比如站在讲台上讲述自己人生中的某个故事。这当然可以很有力量。这就是我谈论鲜明叙事时所指的内容。
share your story and importance of storytelling to create a culture of uncovering talent, I think people feel like they need to have like a set piece where they're standing at a podium and they're telling a story about their own life. And that can certainly be powerful. That's what I'm talking about when I talk about distinct storytelling.
但弥散叙事在某种程度上减轻了这种压力，也就是说，并非所有事情都需要变成“我站在舞台上发表演讲”。它实际上可以只是那种弥散的、非常随意的评论。比如当我提前离开工作去参加孩子学校的戏剧表演时——我昨天刚这么做过——我就说这就是我要去的地方。如果我这么说了，那么我的其他同事就会意识到，如果他们也需要去参加生活中某个重要但不与工作直接相关的活动，
But diffuse storytelling sort of takes a bit of the pressure off, which is to say not everything needs to be I'm standing on a stage and I'm giving a speech. It can really just be this diffuse, very off-handed comment. Like it can be when I'm leaving to go to my kids' school play, which I did yesterday early from work, I say that's where I'm going. So if I say that, then that means that other colleagues of mine realize that if they need to go to some function that's important in their life, that's not work related,
他们同样被允许这么做，因为我已经为他们做出了表率。所以它可以像说一句“这是我今天提前离开的原因”那样随意。它不需要是一篇从讲台上发表的宏大、悲伤、戏剧化的长篇大论。它只需是一段我和某人在喝咖啡时聊起的话题，或者是在Zoom会议结束时顺口说的一句话，诸如此类。
they too have the permission to do that because I've modeled that for them. So it can be as off-handed as saying, this is a reason I'm leaving early today. It doesn't need to be this big, sad, dramatic piece that I'm delivering from the podium. It can just be something that I'm talking to somebody over coffee of, something that I'm saying at the end of a Zoom call or what have you.
或者，如果你在谈论家庭成员，比如谈论你周末做了什么，我们有各种方式向他人展现我们的生活，而不必像你所说的那样，是一篇从讲台上发表的独立场景。百分之百，对吧。你认为这种“揭露”会产生什么效果？你做过一些研究，基本上发现这种讲故事的方式——无论是鲜明形式还是弥散形式——都有益处。
Or if you're talking about a family member, for example, talking about what you did on the weekend, there are ways in which we can reveal our lives to others without it being, as you say, a set piece that's delivered from a podium. 100%, right. What do you think the effects are of this kind of uncovering? You have done some research that basically finds that this kind of storytelling, both the distinct and the diffuse form, have benefits.
是的，我们的研究主要集中在“如果人们期望你掩饰，这对你有什么伤害”这一面上。所以在我们的调查中，我们调查的53%的人表示——这是在《财富》美国500强企业中进行的，也就是在《财富》500强的八个不同行业的3,129名受访者中——他们的领导期望他们进行“掩饰”。而在那53%的人中，有50%的人表示，这在一定程度上极大地削弱了他们对职场或其中社群的承诺。
Yes, our research has mostly been on the side of if people expect you to cover, what is the harm to you? So in our survey, 53% of the people who we surveyed said, this is in the Fortune 500, so this is 3,129 respondents across eight different sectors of the Fortune 500 said that their leaders expected them to cover. And of that 53%, 50% said that this somewhat to extremely diminish their commitment to the workplace or their community there.
是的，我们的研究主要集中在：如果人们期望你掩盖真实自我，对你会有什么伤害？因此，在我们对财富500强企业的调查中，有53%的受访者表示——这是来自财富500强八个不同行业的3,129名受访者——他们的领导期望他们掩盖自我。而在那53%的人中，有50%的人表示这在不同程度上削弱了他们对工作场所或当地社区的投入度。
So this is just evidence that covering demands are hurtful and that they're particularly hurtful when they come from leaders within the organization. I understand, Kenji, some time ago you were at a supermarket and you had an exchange with the cashier. He asked you a question that had to do with your husband, but you didn't tell the cashier about your husband. Tell me that story. Yeah, this is a funny one, which is that we're never done with covering.
这只是证明了掩饰的要求是有害的，特别是当这些要求来自组织内部的领导时，它们尤为有害。我记得，肯吉，不久前你在一家超市和收银员有过一次对话。他问了你一个关于你丈夫的问题，但你没有告诉收银员你丈夫的事。能讲讲那个故事吗？是的，这是一个有趣的故事，说明我们永远都在面对掩饰。
The supermarket story is where, you know, my husband has this kind of guilty pleasure where he's obsessed with the royal family. And so when I see a kind of trashy tabloid about, you know, the royal family, I will buy it for him. And it's kind of a running gag in our family. And it's just a cute, I think, cute thing
超市的故事是这样的，你知道，我丈夫有一种小小的内疚快感，他迷恋皇室成员。所以当我看到一本关于皇室成员的八卦小报时，我会为他买下来。这在我们家里算是一个常开的玩笑，我认为，这是一件很可爱的事。
that we do for each other as a couple. And you know, I was getting ribbed by the cashier for, you know, buying this because the other things I was getting were somewhat more highbrow. So he was like, it's not often that we see somebody buying this book and then this tabloid at the same time. And then I thought, oh, I'm going to say this isn't for me, this is for my husband. And then I thought about it and I thought, well, I'm not going to say this. And then, and this is going to sound like I went through a giant loop, but this all
这是我们作为夫妻为彼此做的事。你知道的，收银员拿我开玩笑，因为我买了这个，而我买的其他东西相对来说更有品位一些。所以他说，我们不常看到有人同时买这本书和这本八卦小报。然后我想，哦，我要说这不是给我的，这是给我丈夫的。接着我想了想，觉得，嗯，我还是不说了。然后，这听起来可能像是我经历了一个巨大的心理循环，但这一切
took place in the course of two seconds, right? But I thought, like, I'm not going to throw my husband under the bus, so I'm not going to say this is for my husband and I remember thinking like oh am I doing this because I'm worried about Saying my husband like am I covering my sexual orientation? I was like no if I'm covering something I'm covering his trashy taste and tabloids And this is actually a very loving protective thing that I'm doing for him rather than speaking from a place of shame So I want to say that I think all of us as human beings like make these lightning fast decisions and I think all I'm asking is that we just drive those decisions a little bit
都发生在两秒钟之内，对吧？但我想，我不能把我的丈夫出卖了，所以我不会说是给我丈夫买的，我记得当时想，哦，我是因为担心说出“丈夫”这个词才这样的吗？我是在掩饰自己的性取向吗？我当时想，不，如果我在掩饰什么，我是在掩饰他那俗气的八卦小报品味，这其实是一件非常充满爱意、保护他的事，而不是出于羞耻感。所以我想说，我认为我们所有作为人类的人，都会做出这种快如闪电的决定，而我认为我所要求的只是，我们让这些决定稍微多一点地浮出水面，进入我们的意识，这样我们在做出这些决定时，能够体现出我们关于自己是谁、以及我们想成为什么样的价值观，同时也体现出我们希望让别人在这个世界上成为什么样的人。肯吉·吉野是纽约大学的法学学者。他是《掩饰：隐藏在我们民权之下的攻击》一书的作者。他与大卫·格拉斯哥合著了《说正确的话：如何谈论身份、多样性与公正》。肯吉，非常感谢你今天来到Hidden Brain。这真是太荣幸了。
more to the surface of our consciousness so that we make these decisions in a way that kind of lives out our values about who we are and who we want to be in the world, and also who we want to let others be in the world as well. Kenji Yoshino is a legal scholar at New York University. He's the author of Covering, The Hidden Assault on Our Civil Rights. Along with David Glasgow, he is co-author of Say the Right Thing, How to Talk About Identity, Diversity, and Justice. Kenji, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It was such a pleasure.
谢谢你。你对肯吉·吉野关于掩饰和身份认同的问题有什么后续吗？如果你愿意与Hidden Brain的听众分享你的问题，请在你的手机上录一段语音备忘录，并通过电子邮件发送给我们，邮箱是ideas@hiddenbrain.org。再说一遍，邮箱地址是ideas@hiddenbrain.org。请使用“covering”（掩饰）作为主题。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保尔、
Thank you. Do you have follow-up questions about covering an identity for Kenji Yoshino? If you'd be willing to share your questions with the Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line covering. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul,
克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德里克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行主编。如果你喜欢我们在Hidden Brain中探讨的理念，请考虑注册我们的播客订阅服务Hidden Brain Plus。在那里你会找到在其他地方听不到的额外对话。此外，你将为我们提供至关重要的支持，使我们能够为你带来更多期的节目。
Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you love the ideas we explore on Hidden Brain, please consider signing up for our podcast subscription, Hidden Brain Plus. It's where you'll find bonus conversations you won't hear anywhere else. Plus, you'll be providing us with vital support to continue bringing you more episodes of
请访问support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问apple.co/hiddenbrain。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
the show. Please go to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, go to apple.co slash hiddenbrain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本节目。请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，请访问 apple.co 斜杠 hiddenbrain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们很快再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。